As we have learned over the years, even the
biggest and best movies in the world often
feature some pretty funny mistakes.
Of course, having a few mistakes doesn’t
make them bad movies – it’s just an extra
fun thing for us to look for!
Enjoy the slip-ups on our list and be sure
to stick around to the end to find out about
some bonus mistakes that our friends over
at The Richest were able to find!
For now, here is 10 Movie Mistakes You Won't
Believe Made The Cut.
Enjoy the video and be sure to hit the subscribe
button to stay up to date with all our new
stuff!
Captain America: Civil War
Captain America: Civil War brought Marvel
some incredible commercial and critical success
and many people have argued that it is the
best MCU film to date.
That being said, the movie isn’t without
it’s fair share of goofs and slip ups.
In the first Avengers briefing with the Secretary,
it can be clearly seen that, in the background,
Tony Stark is wearing a wedding ring.
The problem is, when the shot changes, Tony
can be seen in the same position – but this
time with no ring.
It’s not uncommon for playboys like Mr.
Stark to take off their wedding ring once
and a while but we have to think this was
an editing mistake and not a character choice.
Suicide Squad
Suicide Squad is by no measure a perfect movie,
actually it’s not even close – so it’s
not really surprising that along with the
poor decisions the film made it also made
some visible continuity mistakes too.
When Harley is changing and the whole crew
stops to look at her undeniably hot body,
there is a continuity mistake that totally
slips through.
In the moment right before we see that Will
Smith’s Deadshot is wearing a white shirt.
The movie then cuts to Harleys super hot stripping
scene but when we cut back, Smith is wearing
a totally different dark coloured shirt.
We are guessing that Robbie’s bod distracted
most fans and it looks like the folks editing
Suicide Squad may have been as well.
Doctor Strange
2016’s Doctor Strange is just another example
of how Marvel can take a lesser-known property
and turn it into a serious hit.
With Cumberbatch leading the way, the film
introduced us to some new magical elements
of the MCU, but unfortunately, all the magic
in the world couldn’t fix some mistakes
in this film.
At one point, Stephen Strange is at home looking
for help on a video chat and when he becomes
frustrated he throws everything on his table
to the ground.
Christine then enters with food for him and
when the camera cuts back, we can see that
all of the things he just knocked to the ground
have magically been placed back on the table.
Doctor Strange may have some awesome powers
but we don’t think instant tidying up is
one of them.
The Wolf Of Wall Street
Not counting a 2005 documentary that is literally
called the F word, The Wolf Of Wall Street
holds the record for the most uses of the
expletive in a film with 506 F bombs.
The movie is a wild ride and along with all
the swearing there is also some pretty steamy
sex scenes between Leo and Margot Robbie.
One of these scenes actually features a pretty
funny continuity error as Leo’s pants magically
jump on to his body between cuts after his
final love making session with Robbie.
We’re guessing you probably didn’t catch
this editing mistake as there are a lot of
other things on the screen to be looking at,
but once you’ve seen it, it’s hard not
to laugh at.
Jurassic World
Although it was met with mixed critiques,
there is no denying that Jurassic World was
a commercial success as it raked in well over
1.5 Billion dollars in 2015.
The movie was undoubtedly exciting and Chris
Pratt did a great job with his character but
unfortunately, even with all that money behind
it, the movie still had some visible slip
ups.
In the scene when Hoskins first approaches
the raptor cage, we can see that his watch
shows approximately 2pm.
After the rescue of the staff member who falls
into the pit, the shot cuts back again to
Hoskins and his watch now reads 1pm.
This movie features a lot of crazy science,
but we don’t think it dealt with time travel
so we are going to have to chalk this one
up as a continuity error!
La La Land
La La Land is a force to be reckoned with
as the 2016 Hollywood musical has now officially
tied the record for most Oscar nominations
of all time.
This film takes every last details in to consideration,
but even the most carefully crafted cinema
can fall victim to some continuity issues.
On the day Sebastian (played by Ryan Gosling)
visits Mia (played by Emma Stone) at her coffee
shop, Mia had been shown entering work wearing
black pants and carrying a yellow bag.
But, when Mia leaves work, she is wearing
a blue skirt and holding a red bag.
Over the next few cuts, Mia’s outfit continues
to change from skirt to pants.
It’s a very small mistake and in a movie
that has the actors singing and dancing through
the stars, this little slip up likely goes
unnoticed.
Avengers: Age Of Ultron
The Avengers movies admittedly have a lot
on their plates with all of the characters
and storylines needing to intertwine in just
the right way to make sure everything in the
MCU makes sense.
It is understandable then, how some small
editing errors can slip past the filmmakers
and make it to the final cut.
In Avengers Age Of Ultron’s big chase through
the streets of Seoul, Capt. America's shield
starts out with a few scratches and smudges
that are clearly visible.
While his shield is strong, we don’t think
it has regenerative powers so it must be an
editing mistake that by the end of the chase,
Cap’s shield is magically spotless.
Hell Or High Water
Hell Or High Water was one of the most criminally
underrated and under watched films from 2016
and hopefully it’s Best Picture nomination
will help convince more people to go see it.
If you do take the time to see this thrilling
piece of cinema, try to catch the editing
mistake from the start of the film.
As Ben Foster and Chris Pine are driving off
after their first bank robbery, Foster is
shown taking off his right glove and putting
the hand back on the steering wheel.
But, in the next shot from outside the car,
his gloves have magically jumped back on his
hands.
This is a high intensity moment, so we are
guessing that viewers didn’t catch this
on the first watch, but that’s what we’re
here for!
Zootopia
Zootopia is a lot of a fun and did a great
job of introducing us to some hilarious characters
while also promoting a pretty meaningful message.
One of the best characters in the film is
Yax, who is of course played by the notoriously
chill Tommy Chong.
Unfortunately for Yax, he is the subject of
our latest movie mistake as he completely
messes up what he calls himself.
Yax, who doesn't wear clothes, incorrectly
refers to himself and his fellow nudists as
"Naturalists", which actually means experts
or students of natural history.
What he meant to say, was “Naturists”,
as in people who don’t wear any clothes.
It’s unclear if this mistake was on purpose
or not, but either way, we spotted it!
Deadpool
In one scene
from Deadpool you can clearly see the Merc
with a mouth have his right hand chopped off.
The problem with this is that just a few moments
later, when Deadpool falls into the dumpsters,
you can totally see his hand still attached.
While some people could argue that this is
just Deadpool regenerative power working at
light speed, we think it’s far more likely
that this is just a case of discontinuity,
leaving us with a pretty funny movie mistake.
Deadpool also has another editing mistake
hidden in it, but we can’t take credit for
finding this one.
Check out the video our friends at The Richest
Youtube channel just put out all about shocking
slip ups from some of the biggest films in
recent years, the Deadpool mistake will definitely
surprise you!
While you’re checking out their video, subscribe
to their channel and let them know that the
good people over at Screen Rant sent you!